back with me tonight is josiah
lippencott marine vet
and contributor to american mind josiah
we had such a huge response
to your appearance last night that we
kind of had to cut short because of the
nature of our breaks and i had to bring
you back
some of the last bastions of
traditionalism
in our country law enforcement the
military
they're being transformed
before our very eyes what's the end goal
here in your mind
absolutely that's the perfect question
laura uh just real quickly just from the
introduction
i am not a combat veteran though i am a
veteran i served in the marine corps for
four years
but my experience was with the peacetime
marine corps that's emerged
in the post the post really serious
engagements in afghanistan and iraq and
you ask about what's the end state of
what's happening right now
i think for the military today it is to
keep the money flowing
without having to confront the reality
of the increasing
obsolescence of many of our systems that
are designed to win
wars that america no longer is fighting
you know insurgency is just a different
type of conflict that
our military is not built to defeat
when you heard that disturbingly
frank assessment of our ability
to respond militarily to china
and you think we're spending time with
generals
tweeting about how hillsdale should come
and get you whatever that means they
silence you
talking about critical race theory
whether we have it or don't have it in
the military
china's got to be watching this going
are you kidding me this is who we're up
against
absolutely so one of the difficulties
that comes out of this is that
our military a war with china
another nuclear power is not going to
play out the way that our conventional
military
is designed to address these kinds of
conflicts you know
china is able to manipulate the united
states and wage information warfare in a
way that's way more effective
than anything they can do conventionally
and i think at some level our generals
know this
at the beginning of obama's term there
were a hundred thousand chinese students
in american universities
by the end of his term there were three
hundred thousand
that's a really serious if we're serious
about confronting china
we need to address the uh the industries
that they've taken from us
with the assistance of wall street we
need to address the fact that we're
educating their elite
laura every year 70 000 americans die of
opioid overdose
those drugs those fentanyl is is made in
china
and then it is shipped to mexico and
then smuggled across our border
if our military is serious about
addressing chemical warfare against the
american people
then we need to concentrate on building
a secure border
on defending our national sovereignty
and on restoring
industry back to the united states and
that means
twitter spats with uh with civilians and
veterans
is not the way to go about accomplishing
that uh this general donahoe
is a real piece of work i mean i gotta
say this is
it's embarrassing it's completely
embarrassing now the head of the u.s
central command
made an announcement over the weekend
watch
the united states has increased
airstrikes in the support of afghan
forces
over the last several days and we're
prepared to continue
this heightened level support in the
coming weeks if the taliban continue
their attacks
josiah many are wondering whether the
military
establishment is going to demand that
joe biden reverse course
on an afghanistan withdrawal is that
possibly what's going on here absolutely
i mean there's a lot of money involved
in these wars i mean and that's flowing
to line the pockets of these defense
contractors when generals are done
where they go straight to the boards of
those firms
and so again and look in
at the end of his term the military
admitted publicly in the news that they
had lied to president trump
about troop levels in syria our generals
absolutely would do the same thing to
the to joe biden
and they probably already have so what
is needed is accountability
congress has got to get involved they
need to start asking questions
what are these guys doing overseas and
are you telling the truth
because that cannot be assumed uh well
i think we're having all these
committees on
this or that issue january 6 or it's you
know trying to impeach trump for the
second time
and yet we've lost war after war
or at least haven't won war after war
and then we're supposed to be just
continuing to write these
massive checks
absolutely it's it's absurd i mean
americans have paid
a lot of money in taxpayer dollars we've
paid in blood
we need to have accountability on all
these fronts and i would say this to go
back to general donahoe
that's a guy who graduated from harvard
or has a degree from or one of
one some kind of fellowship from there
and what i would say is
i am willing to challenge that guy to a
debate on policy
on covet policy on foreign policy and on
the military budget
and i'll do it if he wants to come get
me he can come to hillsdale himself
and come get me here and i'll extend
that invitation
to all of our generals and admirals i
will debate your budget
in public with you anytime any place
i'll go to the war college
i'll go to annapolis i'll go to west
point but it's just time
someone has got to hold these guys
accountable and if congress isn't going
to do it then it needs to be everyday
citizens
on social media and in journalism or
in some of these publications to just
hold our leaders to account
josiah thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else